hi there
hi there can you guys hear me can you
hear me in the back
great I'm Dorothy I'm one of the owners
here it's great to see all of you at
labyrinth tonight welcome just a few
practical things and then we'll get
going first please turn off your cell
phones if you haven't done that already
well so our event season is sort of
winding down but we're of course
planning great events for the Fall so if
you don't already get our email invites
and would like to just leave us your
email address on the back counter
there's a sign-up sheet for that in
terms of the the event tonight the
logistics are that I will just do a very
brief introductions Chris will speak and
then there will be time for Q&A I would
just like to ask you we have c-span
booked TV here tonight and I'd like to
ask you to give me a moment to come to
you with a mic so that you either the
whole event can be heard as well as see
and I also want to ask you to try to
formulate really a question rather than
a statement in fairness to everyone else
okay
so it is my great pleasure to introduce
to you and to welcome back to labyrinth
a friend and neighbor Chris Hedges whose
new book wages of rebellion the moral
imperative of revolt
we're honoring and discussing tonight
Chris spent nearly two decades as a
foreign correspondent in Central America
the Middle East Africa and the Balkans
he has reported from more than 50
countries working for many major news
outlets for 15 years he was foreign
correspondent for the New York Times
where he was part of the team of
reporters that was awarded the Pulitzer
Prize in 2002 for the papers coverage of
global terrorism he is the author of
more than a dozen critically acclaimed
books which continue to influence and
inspire those looking for ways to
understand and resist
structural inequalities
and injustice Chris is a senior fellow
at the nation Institute he has caught it
taught at Columbia University nYU
Princeton and in addition to publishing
what seems to be about a bookie here
Chris writes a weekly column for
TruthDig and teaches inmates in New
Jersey prisons with wages of rebellion
Chris continues his work as chronicler
of globalized corporate power of the
suffering and harm it inflicts on humans
and on the environment but while
reminding the reader always of how high
the stakes of inaction are this book is
dedicated mostly to understanding what
it means and what it takes to take
action in particular to take nonviolent
action well there's never in doubt that
the rebels we meet in wages of rebellion
are men and women of great moral and
physical courage that courage is in this
telling almost a secondary effect
primary is the theologian Reinhold
Niebuhr notion of sublime madness this
curious mixture Chris explains of gloom
and hope defiance and resignation of
absurdity and meaning is born of the
rebels awareness of the enormity of the
forces that must be defeated and the
remote chances for success in every
chapter
he draws not only on the history of
political thought and the biography
biographies of rebels through the
centuries and the world over but
crucially also on a large canon of
literary texts our cultural patrimony is
offered as a source from which to draw
strength for a struggle that is
necessarily a struggle against all odds
a reminder of the experience of the
natural world as sacred is offered as
another such source of strength while
Chris's new book is a book of history
reporting and analysis and therefore for
the most part is written in the 3rd in
the 3rd not the first person given the
fact that social justice is the cause to
which Chris has dedicated his own life
wages of rebellion is also an intensely
personal book its last sentence coming
at the end of a tribute to his
Yunis who is here and their children is
I fear I have never done enough the work
of those who resist injustice it would
seem requires not only some form of
sublime madness but also a forever
Restless conscience please join me in
giving Chris a warm welcome
[Applause]
thank you and Thank You Dorthea one of
the great joys of being in Princeton is
having Labyrinth one of the great
bookstores in the United States and it
would be hard to imagine living here
without labyrinth and Firestone library
across the street the three books that I
wrote before wages of rebellion depth of
liberal class Empire of illusion and the
end of literacy and the triumph of
spectacle and days of destruction days
of revolt which I wrote with the great
cartoonist Joe Sacco out of the poorest
pockets of the country including Camden
New Jersey which per capita is the
poorest city in the United States and at
the time we were working there the most
dangerous attempted to portray a
political and economic system that no
longer serve the interests of the
citizen but the exclusive demands of
corporate power in all of those books I
argued that investing our hope and our
energy in the formal mechanisms of power
was a waste of time that we had
undergone what John Ralston Saul calls a
corporate coup d'etat in slowmotion that
it's over they've won that we live
rather in what the political philosopher
Sheldon Wolin
calls a system of inverted
totalitarianism and that is not
classical totalitarianism it doesn't
find its expression through a demagogue
or a charismatic leader but through the
anonymity of the corporate state making
it different from communism and
different from fascism but no less as
effective a totalitarian force so that
we have the facade
of electoral politics of constant the
constitution of the traditional branches
of government but internally
corporations have now seized all of the
levers of power to render the citizen
impotent those were all of those
arguments death of liberal class of
course chronicled the destruction of
liberal institutions which once made
piecemeal and incremental reform
possible labor the Academy the arts
largely commercialized and of course as
Noam Chomsky has written those liberal
institutions acted as a kind of safety
valve to ameliorate the grievances or in
justices of the citizenry and right the
kind of capitalist democracy Roosevelt
indeed said that his greatest
achievement was that he saved capitalism
and that's correct but the destruction
of that mechanism by which you could
address a crisis within capitalism and
of course the New Deal addressing the
breakdown of capitalism itself is gone
we are barreling towards a frightening
global neo feudalism we have empowered a
rapacious oligarchic elite we indeed
live in an oligarchy we have destroyed
the capacity of our working class to
make a sustainable income and the
assault on the middle class is far under
way and at the same time the state the
corporate state is squeezing more and
more and more and rendering the
government less and less effective in
terms of meeting the demands of citizens
and that is borne out now with these
secret trade agreements the TPP and
CAFTA and others where essentially the
power of the state to even intervene in
terms of corporate exploitation is
removed from them now all of this
creates a very frightening kind of
political paralysis an inability of the
state
to respond to the vast majority of the
citizens we see that in the name of
austerity we see that in the way that
the state in order to fund its
activities exploits in greater and
greater measure the poor and the most
vulnerable one of the engines to the
revolts in Ferguson Baltimore in other
places is the fact that poor what
Malcolm s called our internal colonies
derive up to thirty or forty percent of
their income from fining the poor for
absurdities not mowing their lawn
standing for five seconds or walking
they make the rules up as they go along
anybody who's worked in a marginal
community understands the nature of
omnipotent policing something Hanna Erin
warned about in the origins of
totalitarianism and at the same time the
legal system has been utterly inverted
to strip the citizen of its most of his
or her most cherished constitutional
rights we can start with the rights to
privacy the section 1021 of the National
Defense Authorization Act and I sued
Barack Obama in federal court over this
one in the southern district court of
New York and then it was appealed and
overturned it permits the military to
carry out domestic policing in essence
forms of extraordinary rendition on
American city streets seized American
citizens who are deemed to be terrorists
and hold them without due process
indefinitely in military facilities the
inability on the courts to deal with
wholesale surveillance all of us in this
room have all of our information we know
this because of the courage of Edward
Snowden all of our information is
captured downloaded and stored in
perpetuity in government computers once
you have a state and I covered the
collapse of the Stasi state in East
Germany once you have this state that
has the capacity to monitor a citizen 24
hours a day you can no longer use the
word liberty that is the relationship of
a master and a slave the ability of the
executive branch to call for the
assassination of American citizens the
misuse of the Espionage Act
to shut down whistleblowers Drake Yakub
Snowden and others Chelsea Manning all
of this is combining to create a very
frightening dystopia and unfettered
unregulated capitalism as Karl Marx
understood is a revolutionary force that
has no self-imposed limits stripped of
external limits it exploits until
exhaustion or collapse so that even when
you get a figure like Bernie Sanders on
many of the issues I agree with Bernie
although not on his position with Israel
as soon as he signs on to the project of
the Democratic Party and I think his
Ralph Nader has told us for some time
the Democratic Party is as captive to
corporate power as the Republican party
there is no way within the American
political system to vote against the
interests of Exxon Mobil or Raytheon or
Goldman Sachs it's impossible and the
decision by Sanders to work within that
party and not call it out for what it is
essentially allows him to act as a kind
of sheepdog for Hillary Clinton who and
we Clinton's assault against the working
class was perhaps even more draconian
than that carried out by Ronald Reagan
NAFTA the omnibus crime bill 1994 which
exploded the prison population the
deregulation of the FCC the destruction
of welfare seventy percent of the
children on the Assistance Act for
families were stripped of their ability
to receive government benefits
glass-steagall all of this essentially
has propelled us forward to a situation
where as things unravel we no longer
have the legal mechanisms or the
protection by which we can resist and
this is by design the NSA has run
numerous scenarios of the effects of
climate change and we just saw March 400
and 400 parts per million that's the
first time the levels of carbon
admissions has been that high for an
entire month in recorded history these
are the death throes of the planet and
corporate forces exploit until there's
nothing left and in theological terms in
many ways they are there are forces of
death quite literally when we talk about
those forces these of the climate change
that's the reality that we face that is
the political the economic the
environmental reality that we are up
against and the capacity of the state to
control the citizen to monitor the
citizen to use lethal force against
unarmed citizens and all of the marches
by black lives matter all of the
coverage all of the videos that show us
the murder by militarized police forces
of unarmed citizens do nothing the
numbers of citizens keep being killed
every 28 hours a usually young man or
woman of color is murdered unarmed in
this country and and so how do we react
how do we resist what does it take and
and what will the state do that's what I
tried to look at in the book wages of
rebellion the moral imperative of revolt
and I spend time in the book talking
with those who have stood up with
magnificent courage to defy the system
people like Mumia abu-jamal Julian
Assange in the Ecuadorian embassy the
great civil rights attorney Lynne
Stewart herself sent to prison Jeremy
Hammond the hacker I attended with
Cornel West the trials of Chelsea
Manning and we'd leave Princeton he
lives in Princeton we'd leave at 3 in
the morning to drive down to be at Fort
Meade and each lesson was or each car
ride Cornell would usually drive was a
lesson in classic soul so he knows
everything about everything including
classics also he
Bootsy Collins wrote that song for James
Brown when he was 19 and I got a letter
from Chelsea Manning after she was
sentenced and imprisoned she was not
allowed to turn around and look at who
was seated in the courtroom to support
her and I got a letter saying that she
had looked out of the corner of her eye
and seeing Cornell myself and she just
wanted to send a thank-you note I think
the greatest existential crisis of our
time is accepting the reality that is
before us with all its bleakness and yet
finding the capacity to resist and
liberalism itself in the face of a
crisis of this magnitude as Reinhold
Niebuhr has written is an ineffectual
force it's too intellectual
it's too passionless it's too lacking in
that quality that niebuhr called sublime
madness that capacity to rise up in the
face of overwhelming repression and
respond as a moral imperative the
ability of rebels to react to massive
systems of oppression is driven and
Baldwin writes about this by a vision a
vision that takes possession of them
Hana
arrant writes about this where in the
face of and she actually says when she
leaves the University of Heidelberg that
she had to unlearn everything that she
had been taught of course she had
studied with Heidegger in the university
to become a moral human being and she
said that the those who are most
effective in terms of resisting are not
those who ask or say this should not be
done or we oughtn't to do this but who
say I can't that it is that in ability
on
part of the rebel to accept because of
who they are complicity with systems of
injustice and that is what Niebuhr
called sublime madness
James Cohen and his great book the cross
and the lynching tree which I urge you
all to read also plays with this as a
fundamental quality in those who and he
talks of course about the
african-american experience who endure
the horrific forms of racism economic
and legal oppression that are not
unfamiliar in our marginal communities
and and yet have that spiritual resource
to resist in the face of overwhelming
odds what's coming and we see it as the
climate unravels at a faster pace than
climate scientists predicted we just saw
we've seen the Norwegian study up in the
Arctic where they're saying that all of
the measurements in terms of the in
terms of the Arctic ice has been wrong
because that layer of old ice is gone
all the old and it's in fact new ice the
severe drought in California and and
what happens as that society as our
society constricts politically
economically and environmentally is that
the forces of corporate control tighten
the levers are the mechanisms of power
the fact that the corporate eyes media
as one example will talk about the
drought in California and not talk about
the animal agriculture industry which is
fundamental to that drought and in fact
the animal agriculture industry is
arguably the primary industry behind
global warming and yet
the power of those corporations are such
that they have shut out any kind of a
discussion even this critique of
corporate power one that figures like
or Noam Chomsky will give is shut out
those of us who offer this critique are
not offered a platform on national
median Nome and Ralph and I all fine I'm
about to leave for Canada on Friday and
it's one CBC show after another and the
last time I was in Canada speaking at
Ryerson University the CBC filmed the
show and here we want to thank c-span
for being here but they filmed the show
and and devoted a one-hour program to it
that is impossible within the United
States I used to wonder whether Huxley
was right or Orwell was right and I
think it turns out that they're both
right in a sense that what we first got
was Huxley and as we were fleeced as we
now reach a state where we can't get
credit where all of those cheap
manufactured consumer products are no
longer easily accessible or available in
Sheldon Wolin as great book democracy
incorporates and incorporated calls that
those consume the access to cheap credit
and consumerism one of the two primary
forms of political control once those
are removed then we increasingly get the
iron boot the iron fist that Orwell
predicted so it turns out I think that
Orwell and Huxley were both right and we
are seeing now that transformation as
you get a huge underclass pushing 50% of
this country in terms of poor and near
poor unable to sustain a living chronic
underemployment or unemployment which of
course the statistics mask once you stop
looking for work you're no longer
counted as unemployed or if you have a
part-time job at Walmart twenty-eight
hours a week most workers at Walmart
that's the average they work you're
still put below the poverty line so you
are given applications for food stamps
and you qualify we subsidize the walden
fortune the walton family making about
eleven thousand dollars a year
I think that ultimately for me and I
come out of seminary I come out of a
theological background that resistance
is is finally not determined by what
empirically is around us and that gets
to what father Daniel Berrigan who
baptised our youngest daughter when he
defines faith he says that faith is the
call to do the good or at least the good
insofar as you can determine it and then
you let it go the Buddhists call it
karma faith is the belief that even if
all of the empirical evidence around you
says otherwise
the good goes somewhere and I think that
for the rebel like the religious mystic
it is this faith that finally defines
our capacity to resist because the
forces that we are facing are deadly and
immense and are unlike any totalitarian
force that human societies have faced in
the past why is there wholesale
surveillance and we can look at past
totalitarian regimes to understand it is
because you gather all of the
information on the citizenry so that the
moment that you need it you can use it
it's not about justice it's not about
innocence it's not about who committed a
crime or who didn't it is about that
moment that they decide to criminalize
an entire segment of the population and
have whatever it is on your file that
they can reach out and twist and use
against you that is why all of our
electronic correspondents our medical
records virtually everything about us
which by the way is now a big business
corporations sell all this stuff and
they have everything on you but that's
why it's there
and it is that again that fusion of both
corporate and political power which is
indistinguishable of our 16 intelligence
agencies this is why Snowden was working
for a private contractor 70% of the
intelligence is outsourced to private
corporations and and they are using that
intelligence as assiduously and as
cruelly as the state itself at this
point there is no difference the the the
misuse of the judiciary by judicial Fiat
to strip off strip us of constitutional
rights so that for instance the right to
privacy is not addressed by the courts
in very nefarious and dark ways when I
sued the president I was also part of
the lawsuit that reached the Supreme
Court clapper versus Amnesty
International and that was challenging
the warrantless wiretapping under the
FISA Amendment Act oh this is before the
Snowden revelations and the government
lawyers stood up in court in the Supreme
Court and said it's speculation the
plaintiffs charged that they are being
monitored by the state of speculation
and if they were being monitored the
government would tell them which we now
know from Snowden is a lie but the court
bought it and at that same time the
Obama administration which had
challenged it that the day of judgment
with the temporary injunction declaring
section 1021 of the NDAA
unconstitutional the day of the ruling
they sent lawyers not just government
attorneys federal attorneys but
attorneys from security agencies into
her chambers and demanded that she
reinstate to lift the temporary
injunction reinstate the law in the name
of national security which to her credit
she refused they went then the next week
went to the appeals court the Second
Circuit demanded the same thing and they
did put it back into effect the law back
into effect and Carl Mayer who's here
was his father our know the great
historian
and Bruce Afrin honor of Bruce's here
the great lawyers on this case who did
all the works and I you know I just had
to show up in a coat and tie but we all
wondered why and and I think our
supposition was they're already using
the law and probably black sites like
Bagram and other places and so they they
the the Second Circuit waited until the
Supreme Court ruled and then the case
was called hedges versus Obama he said
the plaintiffs and hedges versus Obama
or the plaintiffs in the Supreme Court
clapper versus Amnesty International
don't have standing on credibility
therefore they don't have it in hedges
versus Obama now that that's an example
of how the court plays a very dirty game
by which it it doesn't rule on on the
clear unconstitutionality of deploying
the military as a domestic police force
and seizing American citizens as
terrorists and stripping them of due
process it skirts it in the same way
that Citizens United defines unlimited
corporate cash as petitioning the
government of free speech this is just
over and over and over that the court
systems have been used to strip us
legally we have created omnipotent
policing beginning in marginal
communities places where doors can be
kicked down in the middle of the night
militarized police entered with long
barrel weapons these are for nonviolent
warrants often drug warrants entire
families are terrorized you only ninety
four percent of people in America
actually get a trial the police stack
you with so many charges most of which
you didn't commit and then they offer to
strip off a few as a plea and if you
actually go to court they're gonna make
an example of you your sentence is going
to be longer and I can give you numerous
examples from the students that I teach
when you get inside the prison system
and you see what's been done to the poor
this system of neo slavery because of
course it is built on the exploitation
100 million prisoners now work mostly
for large corporations target Pierre
Cardin there the model
if you want to know what the corporate
state wants for the rest of us walk
inside our systems are the system of
mass incarceration because they're the
model worker no benefits no health
insurance they always show up to work on
time and should they actually protest
their conditions or attempt to organize
they're sent off to solitary confinement
where they're locked away for so long
they often go insane tens of thousands
of American prisoners are in solitary in
this country Britain puts three to four
prisoners a year in solitary and the
economic engines that now drive it mean
that these corporations are writing the
legislation and so those prisons I think
become a kind of model for where we're
headed as we are steadily stripped of
our rights and the struggle before us is
one where we are going to have to face
the an assault on the ecosystem which
even if we stopped emitting carbon today
would still trigger catastrophic change
it is the creation and we see it these
trade deals which are just NAFTA on
steroids
well weakening the power of the
government to curb or Holt corporate
exploitation and all of that means that
the only mechanism left by which we can
save ourselves and save our children is
to begin to carry out acts of mass civil
disobedience and that requires taking to
the streets I covered the revolutions in
Eastern Europe East Germany
Czechoslovakia Romania and I watched day
after day hundreds of thousands five
hundred thousand people in our lives
under Platz half a million people in ven
salah square in prague and i was every
night in czechoslovakia in the magic
lantern theater with Vaslav Havel and
Klaus and dims beer all the people who
would inherit the
and Havel for me it was a kind of model
of what it means to be a dissident what
it means to rebel he had of course begun
with charter 77 in 1977 in 1978 writing
his great essay the power of the
powerless calling upon us to live in
truth to expose I am by living in truth
exposing the system for what it was and
and that of course is the great terror
of the system that it is exposed for the
predatory creature that it has become
and Havel was not a particularly
charismatic figure or even a very good
speaker but he had the moral authority
there was no question in Prague and I
remember that winner all through the
streets of the city there were posters
of a young Charles University student
named Yann Pollock who to protest the
Soviet invasion which had overthrown
Dubcek Andrey stated a pro Soviet regime
had gone to Wentzel a square and lit
himself on fire four days later he died
of his wounds and the funeral procession
of students from Charles University to
the graveyard was broken up by the
police it was never reported of course
it was a non-event and we have many non
events now in this country including the
the the poor in this country who've been
rendered invisible by a corporate media
unless they cater to the stereotype of
what our our president called him thugs
and criminals without understanding the
long slow drip of humiliation pain
despair indiscriminate violence that
causes them to react as we would react
if we were enduring the same form of
oppression and when they buried
Pollock's body his grave became a shrine
they exhumed his remains they cremated
them they gave them to his mother and
said she could not bury them
a week after the communist government
fell 10,000 people went to Red Army
Square and renamed it yon Pollux Square
that winter there were also there was I
was also in when Salah Square when the
singer mark tacuba shaiva walked out on
that balcony and she had sung the prayer
to Marta the anthem of defiance that was
a call to resistance in 1968 and when
Dubcek was overthrown her recording
stock was destroyed she was banned from
the airwaves and in the intervening
years she had worked on an assembly line
in a toy factory she walked out on that
balcony and began to sing the prayer for
Marta and every check in the crowd knew
every word that is the moral power of
resistance of living in truth and that
is what beragon talked about that when
you stand up for justice even at that
moment when it seems that everyone
around you is passive and doesn't see
you or hear you in fact that truth seeps
out and that's what I took away from
those revolutions from people like
Vaslav Havel
they are those ironic points of light
they hold forth that narrative that at a
certain moment becomes a conflagration
rebellion finally is not carried out for
what we succeed but for who it allows us
to become
I fight fascists not because I'm going
to win but I fight fascists because they
are fascists and that is the moral
parrot of imperative of revolt it is the
call to stand up and do what is right in
the face of overwhelming and even deadly
odds with the recognition that we may
not succeed indeed most of us may not
succeed but we cannot use the word hope
if we are not willing to rebel thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah I think yes all right I'm gonna
go from here to over there
as someone who's written about
democratization in the rest of the world
not here I've been struck with the
protest Street protests in the last few
years that deal with corruption lack of
democracy in people's own countries one
of the issues or problems with those
protests however is that they are not
already not connected or networking
sufficiently with other forces in their
own societies such as what I call
democratization NGOs for example they're
not their anomic in other words they're
not tied to the institutions which might
help them or support them I don't know
whether you want to make a parallel here
but it strikes me that that's an
inherent problem with protest movements
with street protests no you raise a good
point that if there is not an
alternative political vision and if
there is not a political expression of
that vision then those movements become
chaotic and anarchic and are easily put
down and that's where we have to look
for Greece at Greece or Spain with
podemos cerveza in Greece 10 years ago
cerveza was polling 4% and I think and
I've spoken to Shama Sawant the
socialist city council woman in Seattle
about this at length and I think her
point is correct that we have to begin
to build movements that have a political
expression this was I think Bernie
Sanders great mistake and not running as
an independent but the goal the system's
gamed I worked for Ralph Nader and a
longtime admirer and supporter of Nader
so I understand intimately
all the obstacles they throw up to
essentially lock out anybody who doesn't
conform to the Democratic or republican
mold but if we see elections as
essentially furthering a movement rather
there's an end in and of themselves and
this is something we're gonna Shawn and
I will be meeting with others in New
York at the end of the month I'm gonna
go out and kick off
campaign rally in Seattle on the 6th and
I don't want to run and she doesn't want
to run so we got to find some
sacrificial lamb or we've tried to
convince Cornell but he doesn't want to
do it we but I think that's right I
think that that and this is where we
have to look at Europe but the the
secret is building the movements because
it's the movements has Howard Zinn
understood
it's the movements that none of which
achieve formal positions of power that
open up the space in American democracy
the Liberty Party that fought slavery
the suffragists the labor movement they
eat the civil rights movement and the
most powerful political figure in
America until he was murdered
assassinated in 19 in April 1968 was
king because when he went to Memphis or
he went to Selma 50,000 people went with
him which is why Johnson and the power
establishment were terrified of him and
that is the point Karl Popper makes that
point in the open society and its
enemies that the question is not how do
you get good people to rule that's the
wrong question papa rights most people
attracted to power he says are mediocre
or venal the question is how do you make
the power elite frightened of you so
that there's a Kissinger memoirs don't
buy the book he and Nixon are looking
out a window in the White House I think
it's 71 there's a huge anti-war
demonstration they have busts empty city
buses and kind of as barricades all
around the White House and Nixon's going
Henry they're gonna break through the
barricades and get us and that's just
where we want people in power to be and
that's why Nixon was the last liberal
president we had not because he was
liberal or had a heart but because he
was frightened of movements the mine and
Safety Act OSHA the Clean Water Act all
of which were authored by Nader is
pushed through with a functioning
liberal wing of the Democratic Party
that has now been destroyed courtesy of
Bill Clinton and and and we lost that
understanding that it's not our job to
take power it is our job to build
movements that hold power accountable
and that's what unfortunately we've lost
those movements in the name of
anti-communism
they has been a century of destruction
labor the old anarchist movement the old
CIO the Wobblies the Communist Party
which whatever you think of the
Communist Party was sitting down
integrating lunch counters long before
King in the civil rights movement which
that's been that we that that is history
has been completely erased from American
consciousness and the destruction of the
state ellen Trekker writes about this in
no ivory tower the purging of the
universities and our other books I think
such were the crimes fell thousands upon
thousands of journalists social workers
high school teachers artists all of whom
were pushed out of the society and
blacklisted the FBI she writes would
show up at a high school with a list of
six or seven teachers no evidence they
were gone and they could never get
another job the ACLU is purged they're
all purged and this was done by design
and all of the blood that was spilled
the American labor wars were the
bloodiest in the industrialized world
the blood of those workers that created
the middle class that opened up the
space in our society all of that
sacrifice has been rolled back and we
have to rise up with that same
sacrificial spirit and that same
ferocity of holding fast to moral
imperatives to build movements because
in that sense I'm an anarchist I think
power is always the problem and we must
build movements that hold power
accountable and we have to start now
thank you thank you for your talk it's
very interesting we certainly need a
critical mass of people a very large
number people stand up against the power
lead our government the corporations but
don't you think it's going to take a
massive catastrophe on the level of like
right what you raised a good point
it's a it's a very important point
because if you look and I write I do
look back at you know 1848 and other
cycles historians write revolutions tend
to come in waves and this wave is
beginning but it's usually a crisis
so all of the tinder is there and I
think all of the tinder is there but
what is it that sets it off it's often
something relatively banal so the first
Palestinian Intifada is set off by a
traffic accident where seven Palestinian
day workers are killed by the driver and
Israeli truck it's just a point where
people have had enough I mean the the
murder by militarized forces of
occupation that we call the police of
people of color is not new but it's
finally enough and but you're right that
it's that the the encroachment of the
state in terms of the stripping away of
our rights and the more draconian forms
of control it in a moment of crisis it's
it it exposes itself so when errant in
origins of totalitarianism writes about
omnipotent policing she's writing about
the stateless and she was stateless left
Germany stripped of her passport has no
rights in France
she said when you create legal and
physical mechanisms of omnipotent
policing which we have done of course in
the war on drugs and the criminalization
of poverty then when the society breaks
down it becomes very dangerous because
you already have both the legal and the
physical mechanism to use those forces
against the society at large but you're
right it is a crisis I covered the
breakdown of Yugoslavia
it was hyperinflation that triggered the
unrest and we must there's a chapter in
the book called vigilante violence we
have to understand that America is a
deeply violent culture it is a culture
that is a society that is founded on
genocide and slavery that Faulkner gets
it that is the original sin we carry it
within our DNA today the systems of mass
incarceration is neo slavery it has been
changed or mutated it's like has a
protein quality but it's all slavery by
another name and the you know the moment
that the state feels seriously
threatened is the moment that the mask
will fall
and what is a common experience for the
poor and especially the urban poor will
become an experience for the rest of us
so that moment of crisis if we're not
prepared could be seized by
proto-fascist movements we have no
shortage of them the Christian right the
Tea Party the lunatic fringe of the
Republican Party I mean we have to give
Clinton is do
he turned the Democratic Party into the
Republican Party the Democratic Party in
Europe would be a far-right party and he
pushed the Republicans so far to the
right they became insane
and and and and the state if it feels it
already feels it's already worried I
mean the NSA has run scenario after
scenario on climate break down and
Romney they know what's coming they're
ready this is not you know the the the
rise of these forces of and that's what
happens when empires go down you bring
the draconian and violent forces of
control on the outer reaches of empire
that we internally don't see back into
the heart of empire and that's how we
get militarized police wholesale
surveillance drones you know all
stripping away of civil liberties those
are the standard mechanism by which
Empire perpetuates itself so it's the
disease of empire come back and visit it
upon all of us who are complacent while
crimes were being committed in our name
can you hear me mr. Fujiyama was here
recently and he spoke but not as
strongly as you did about the current
situation I agree with everything you
said and I don't know whether we need a
disaster but when I observed Occupy Wall
Street which was a grassroots movement
nothing really happened in the end
and when you look back at the
anti-vietnam war movement you had
powerful leaders powerful minds
committed with moral authority you're
one of those persons why don't you start
one you'll there'll be thousands of
people who will follow you
people who write about it
are committed but we need powerful
voices and leaders like you to gather
the grassroots well that that is you
know my differentiation because in the
end I'm a writer and I don't go before
audiences even in Zuccotti Park and tell
them what they want to hear I was very
critical the black bloc anarchists which
did not win me friends in the Occupy
movement but as I told many of the
people in the Occupy movement the moment
I need your adulation I'm finished it's
my job as a writer to try and speak the
truth insofar as I can determine it
I think the Occupy movement was a
profound and seismic event in modern
American history because it was the rise
of what bakunin called the de classe
intellectuals remember Marx dismissed
the day class say intellectuals although
you know both Marx and Lenin were
intellectuals and and Bakunin was right
so what you got in occupy were largely
the sons and daughters of the white
middle class who had taken out
tremendous loans horrible loans found
themselves thrown into horrific debt
peonage
couldn't get jobs and there was no place
for them in the society as they assumed
and as they had been told by all through
their lives and by the institutions in
which to which they went into debt to
attend that there would be and so that
role the rise of the de classe
intellectuals uniting with service
workers and the working poor in this
country I think was extremely important
we have to remember that there were all
sorts of problems internally especially
after the tense went up that's when the
drugs came in we saw some sexual assault
in Zuccotti but the in the end the
Occupy movement was destroyed it was
destroyed in a coordinated federal
effort led by President Barack Obama and
I think we have to look at occupy as a
tactic as and in the same way that the
Freedom Rides were a tactic you know you
and then the integration of buses and
Montgomery where tactic these are
tactics and something's coming it may
not look like occupy may not call itself
occupy we are seeing it with the
radicalization
of black youth who are showing in places
like Ferguson a political sophistication
remember Jesse Jackson and Al Sharpton
were booed out of Ferguson when when
they tried to show up and hold events
there
Jackson was literally driven out of the
city and never came back because they
looked at that black elite the way and
and and and that's how that black elite
functions it functions this is corporate
colonialism so you push face you push
out a Barack Obama who does the bidding
of corporate power and those kids in
Ferguson who didn't attend Princeton get
it in a way that I suspect some of those
kids at Princeton do not get it and they
because they have been victims of that
oppression and and you know one of the
leaders of hands up United was invited
to the White House and Obama asked him
did you vote for me he said no I'm not
going to vote for you just because
you're black
that would be shallow that's those are
his words t-dub oh the great is great
hip-hop artists and and so that is a
level of I mean the whole sort of focus
on gender or race is anti politics it's
anti political there's no political
content to it and what we have in
presidential elections are and and
Hillary's about to spend what two and a
half billion dollars they are
manufactured personalities they use the
sophistication of the public relations
industry to make us confuse how we are
made to feel with knowledge and they
create fictitious personas that appeal
to us and that we vote for this is not
politics
it's absurdist political theater and and
those students I teach in a prison and
those kids in Ferguson are probably way
ahead of most of the people in Princeton
New Jersey in your latest column you you
write against a Bernie Sanders campaign
but it seems to me that a campaign
led by a self-described socialist in
this country
that was able to generate some
grassroots support from rank-and-file
democrats and independence would only
help to build a radical movement right
it wouldn't hurt it right but but that
that would be if it was carried out
outside the Democratic Party and that
was Sanders mistake that is what he is
not doing so if you want to find out
what happens when you declare yourself
as a socialist and then serve corporate
power you can look at all owned in
France who's probably destroyed the
Socialist Party in France for a
generation but why couldn't it possibly
help to build an independent radical
movement because all those followers
once they're either disappointed or
betrayed they're gonna need somewheres
else to go right well they were already
disappointed in betrayed by Barack Obama
the problem is that he's not going to be
allowed to run unless he agrees to
endorse Hillary Clinton so by next April
he's out and what he does is he then
works to push his supporters those
self-defined liberals and progressives
back into the dead space of the
Democratic Party and he did not run as
an independent because he didn't want to
lose his committee chairmanships and he
knew what the Democratic Party would do
to him
because he saw what they did to Ralph
Nader and that's not speculation because
I've asked him about it and there were
several of us who pushed him or asked
him to run as an independent he refused
to do it well that's what we have to do
it and it's not you know it's not the
leaders that are going to save us
radical change is only ratified or
acknowledged in Parliament's or
congresses it comes from the street and
you see in a moment of seismic change a
kind of swinging back and forth you saw
it the French Revolution so you create
the the National Guard under Lafayette
which is a counter revolutionary force
which is firing and then the French rise
up again there's a kind of swinging back
and forth as the counter-revolutionary
elites seek to seize control and push
back on the rebel
ocean and the the advance of the
revolution so the the whole point is
that without movements it's a sterile
exercise that we have to invest our
energy into building radical movements
that push back and frighten centers of
power and you know occupy frightened
Wall Street occupy frightened more than
I think the occupiers realized it they
terrified the stain we'd really
terrified the state was when mothers and
fathers from New Jersey were coming into
Zuccotti and pushing their strollers up
and down that really frightened them
because essentially it was mainstreaming
the movement which is why they had to
demonize it you know the state is
fragile the Chicago teacher teachers are
marching through the streets of Chicago
they go into a precinct office to use
the bathroom and the police applaud that
terrifies the state a couple years ago
I'm with a veterans for peace 133 of us
most mostly vets are arrested in front
of the White House and it turns out that
the cops have been in the National Guard
they've been in Iraq and Afghanistan and
as they cuff us and it happened to me
they whisper in your ear keep protesting
these worse now the state knows that and
that's why the state passed the NDAA
because it doesn't trust the police to
protect them all revolutions are
nonviolent not colonial wars but
colonial uprisings but revolutions
because no revolution succeeds crane
Brinton and other theorists of
revolution who I quote in my book write
about this no revolution succeeds until
the foot soldiers of the elite the
security forces the police the military
will no longer defend them that's how
the Tsar was overthrown the Cossacks go
into Petrograd for the bread riots they
refuse they they've fraternize with a
crowd the Czar's rushed back on a
railway line he abdicates on the siding
he doesn't even get back to Petrograd in
when I covered the revolution in East
Germany Erich Honecker he'd been in
power 19 years he sends down an elite
paratroop division to Leipzig to fire on
the crowd they get there they won't do
it Honaker
out in another week and because we have
the most dangerous weapon in our hands
which is the truth about power and about
the state once we stand up and are no
longer afraid and they are manufacturing
fear in this country at a rate I was in
Amtrak and it was saying if you see
something say and the end of the video
the person's being cuffed and taken away
just as a reminder they are terrified
and if we lose the capacity for fear and
if we stand up in a non-violent manner
to live in truth and I saw it in the
Stasi State in East Germany then it
creates paralysis within the systems of
power they may use violence but they
ultimately won't use it effectively
because there's too many people who
don't want to carry it out because
there's too many people who have
relatives out in those crowds when they
went to get those paratroopers and bring
them into the streets of leipzig they
were crying because their families and
friends are on the streets of leipzig
and they didn't want to shoot them and
they did not shoot them and we have that
capacity if we build the critical mass
to expose corporate power for what it is
but it requires us to go out in the
street getting arrested is more time
than I care to donate to the US
government but I'm afraid that's the
only option we have and we have no time
left as the latest report on carbon
emissions in the month of March has
shown us we have no time left
thank you I agree with you that it's a
turvy Topsy time I would like to know
how many fascists you've met that know
they are fascist since you're calling
them the enemy and that doesn't count
those who know they're part of the chain
and want to break it there's a good book
by a German thesa wait male fantasies I
pronounced it right Dorthea what David
light there thank you
and he argues I think correctly that in
the end fascism doesn't really have any
ideology
despite this thing about corporatism and
Mussolini I mean you know fascism has a
very often uncomfortable relationship
with business because unlike inverted
totalitarianism where the primacy of
corporate profit takes precedence over
everything in fascism and and Wolin
makes this point in his great book
democracy incorporated you will carry
out things that are not economic don't
economically make sense so you know your
railway system is being bombed to
smithereens at the end of the war and
you're using it to ship more Jews you
know off to Sobibor or outfits so how
many fascists know they're fascists most
fascists defined themselves as Patriots
I would describe the whole celebration
of American sniper as a form of fascism
and all of those people who decided to
cheer every time in that movie some
Iraqi was killed as expressing fascist
sentiments proto fascism is alive and
well in America it always has been the
Klan as is a kind of you know
quintessential fascist organization and
what fascist movements do is they
channel with the most retrograde
elements of American capitalism sheldon
adelson
the koch brothers it channels a
legitimate rage towards the vulnerable
undocumented workers Muslims liberals
homosexuals feminists I have a very long
list of
they despise and and that is part of the
current of American society and that's
why I wrote a chapter called vigilante
violence because we are not Canada we
have a very dark we are a very violent
culture and in times of distress
I mean oh those workers who died we're
usually shot by vigilantes baldwin-felts
Pinkertons gun thugs and not to mention
the terror that was visited on African
Americans not only through the Klan but
the white leagues and the red shirts and
think it was North Carolina on and on
and on so that is also part of our DNA
and a very frightening part of our DNA
which means that the backlash that I
think is finally coming could in very
possibly be a very frightening
right-wing backlash where people cry out
for for authority for hyper-masculine
Authority but I think that notion of
hyper masculinity I think it's kind of
very very insightful and we see it with
the celebration of the military in the
United States the celebration of
military quote-unquote virtues the you
know hierarchy of the military I mean
there's a kind of state religion at this
point built around the military that's
that's very scary so we have time
unfortunately just for one more question
and your hand here hasn't up I've been
reading your truth date column for quite
a few years now and I want to recommend
to everyone who hasn't read the most
recent I thought it was the most precise
the most concise distillation of years
worth of your thank you thank you a
tennis match began in the blog after
your column of people crying out on both
sides you have to vote in the next
election locally nationally no you can't
vote in the next election you're you're
not voting will be the protest can you
comment
well I mean as Emma Goldman said if
voting was that effective it would be
illegal I mean I will vote as a protest
vote so I supported Nader until 2008 I
voted for Jill Stein in 2012 I think
Jill is running again but my fears that
somehow people think that voting is
important every totalitarian state I
covered including Saddam Hussein had
elections Stalin had written the most
enlightened Constitution
in human history and I think you
promulgated it at the height of the
purges in the 30s so voting is utterly
tangential not so much locally and
that's why I am working to support Sawan
I'll do this fundraiser for her in New
York at the end of the month and then
we'll go out to Seattle to help her
begin her campaign because the
Democratic establishment not just in the
state of Washington but in nationally is
determined to destroy her because like
Nader she exposes them the bankruptcy of
the party and that's why she has to be
destroyed so I think you're right
locally you know there can be some
important because you don't need the
massive sums of cash but by the time you
get on the national stage then I do vote
but I'm and I don't I just don't think
it that that voting means that much at
this point invite all of you to linger a
little bit and we can continue the
conversation but for now let's join in
thanking Chris
[Applause]